الى ملف اخر في زياره هي الاولى لمستشار
الالماني منذ 30 عاما اجتمع المستشار علا
تشوز برئيسي كوريا الجنوبيه يونسوكيول
اجتماع نتج عنه تعهدا بين الزعيمين بمزيد
من التعاون في انشاء سلاسل توريد صناعيه
مستقره ومواجهه المخاطر النوويه التي
تشكلها كوريا الشماليه رئيس كوريا
الجنوبيه اكد ان مكانه الشراكه في سلسله
التوريد ستساعدهما في التعامل مع تنامي
عدم الاستقرار في الاقتصاد العالمي
والصراعات الجيو السياسيه كما شدد على ان
الدولتين ستعملان على تعزيز العلاقات
التجاريه بالاضافه الى استكشاف المزيد من
الفرص في مجالات التعاون الدفاعي وفيما
يخص كوريا الشماليه اشاره يون الى انه قام
بتوجيه رساله ثابته الى المجتمع الدولي
مفادها
ليس لديها ما تجنيه من استفزازاتها التي
وسطها بغير القانونيه
[موسيقى]
سنعمل معا لتحقيق التشغيل السادس لسلسله
امداد الصناعات الدفاعيه من خلال التوقيع
الفوري على اتفاقيه بين كوريا الجنوبيه
والمانيا تهدف الى حمايه المعلومات
العسكريه السريه سنوضح انه لا يوجد شيء
يمكن ان تكسبه كوريا الشماليه من
الاستفزازات غير القانونيه وسنواصل ارسال
رساله الى المجتمع الدولي والعمل معا بشكل
وثيق من اجل نزع السلاح النووي لكوريا
الشماليه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات